The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: It's going to
be a strange new rhythm, not
turning up here on Tuesdays
and Thursdays endlessly.
It's been an incredible saga.
We have a minute,
because Thursday will not
be a good time for doing it.
I'd like to spend five minutes
or 10 minutes with you.
I can't ask for advice as
to how to do it better.
Thank God I won't have to.
But I'd be interested
in your general comments
about what we tried to do.
I'd like to pass it on, too.
Since 1956, this class has
been taught every year.
That's 44-- 57 years.
After 57 years, it should
be retired, which it is.
Whether it will continue
in any form or another
is not up to me.
There's a rule, thank God,
where that if you retire,
your successors are independent.
They have to bear the burden
of their predecessors.
And fortunately,
this class will be
recorded for archival
purposes, so they
won't be able to get
rid of me that easily.
Let's just spend a
few minutes having
a little discussion about
this enormous problematic area
dealing with the non-European,
non-American world,
and non-selective Asian world.
It's called, in some terms,
the developing world.
Now, the new name for
it is the Global South.
That is the term which has
been appropriated by the newest
attempt to galvanize
international and professional
interest in an apparently
new way of doing things.
You must recall that I said
that 1950 was the first time
a book in English--
and probably in any language--
appeared on the subject
of the so-called world
of international poverty.
This was not Freidrich Engels
writing about Manchester,
or what could be seen
as its equivalent.
But Charlie Abrams at MIT was a
lawyer who had worked in India,
and decided to come back
here and write about it.
He was a New Yorker writing
about the emerging problems
of population
growth and poverty.
It's curious that
when looking back
on the situation in
Manchester in 1830,
when the young German could
write about and analyze
the industrial poverty, that
the sudden leap of economy
had taken in Great Britain only
since some 80 years before,
if we count 1750 as
the beginning date.
Engels and Marx were--
Engels particularly was
dissatisfied with the pace
of recalibration in England.
He dismissed the moves
of the Chartist Group
as being ineffective.
The British move first
through charity, then
through the state
and the nation,
paying attention to what
is called social housing.
It was definitive.
It was the first
nation in the world
to tackle this problem
systematically-- not
systematically.
Partially.
But had Engels waited around
in England until today,
he might have seen that it
had measures of success,
despite Maggie
Thatcher's involvement
in the interim over a period.
And keep on remembering
that the British are
slow but determined.
I quoted sir Joseph Paxton,
the builder of the Crystal
Palace, the gardener
who said, we do things
by common sense and technology.
Almost everything
was commonsensical,
and even in regard to
science and the development
of massive waves of
technological innovation
the world had ever seen.
Above all, I remind
you that what happened
was the first destruction of
the Malthusian trap, which
is fundamental.
As urbanists, you
should remember
as one of the key factors
in human development.
In my little talk on Friday,
I'll start with, I think,
the first, and
that's the increase
in human brain size from 400
cubic centimeters to 1,450,
and what caused that.
The Malthusian trap,
you will recall,
equated population
growth with death.
The stable size of
population was all
that agricultural innovation
could supply, or could
forestall.
And the sudden capacity
to unleash a population
to move relatively freely
with the advent of the larger
migration patterns that I
think that we see now, where--
anyway.
London became the
largest city in the world
in a very quick manner.
We're not lecturing
about London,
although it's tempting
to recall London.
Such a great story.
Engles took to the road.
He and Marx were
in Paris in 1848.
And then Engels spiriting
himself all over Europe,
nurturing, evolving Marxism,
until eventually, of course,
after his death, Russia
succeeded in attempting
to transform the world.
That transformation
was built on the image
of industrial poverty.
No advertisement--
I mean, the book
Sotsgorod, written by
Milyutin, the Russian architect
and bureaucrat, starts
off with a photograph
of the industrial city,
smoke belching out of pipes,
workers disenfranchised.
I can't think of
anything else that
forced the publicity of the
attempt to nationalize poverty.
The story of the so-called
third world is different.
The battle against
poverty in Europe
was on the basis of a
history of development.
There are very poor
people in Vienna today.
Vienna, since the liberals took
over from the royalty in 1870,
1860s, went through various
exercises, including the rabid,
the rampant, period of Red
Vienna in the 1920s after
the '14-'18 war, which
produced the Karl Marx-Hof,
Matteotti-Hof.
It's interesting that the
reaction of the major cities
that we looked at,
the five major cities,
each produced a
specific housing type.
London produced the
residential square.
Paris produced the boulevard
house, the Haussmannian
boulevard house.
Vienna produced the [INAUDIBLE],,
the first large palace-like
condominium building,
and the hof.
Barcelona produced
the square block
of Cerda and the Ensanche.
So it's extraordinary
that every major attempt
to reformulate the
form of the city
produces a new housing
type in its wake.
Chicago-- I don't
know what it did.
Chicago probably didn't
produce a housing type.
The genesis of the
American suburban house
is old and starts with
the British conquest.
So [INAUDIBLE] we
switch back and then
analogically to the
condition of poverty
in the developing world.
Of all the demonstrations of
international cooperation,
I argued that the Olympic
Games stands out as the most
regular and beneficent.
Nobody objects to
the Olympic games.
They should have in
'36, but they didn't.
Certainly, the Americans didn't.
The Olympic Games has been held,
in all of its years since 1896,
only once in a city in which
the majority of people are poor.
That's Mexico.
It's 1968.
The funding of the
Olympic Games is either
in favor of a national
economic gain,
advertising yourself on the
international economic platform
or, at best, gratifying
a national impulse
to be worldly and international
and, even more at best,
to satisfy perhaps a plangent
ambition in all of us
to be part of a good world,
which is seldom available,
where people run in
peace against each other
as they did in 1896 in Athens.
But the options for the
developing world are few,
because of two meta-conditions--
first of all, the
residue of colonialism
and the emancipation of wealth
from sources such as Mexico,
from sources such as India
through the cotton trade,
from almost every African
country, gold and diamonds
and uranium from South
Africa; secondly,
particularly in Africa,
the incipient tradition
of tribalism.
Tribes were-- the world
was born in Africa.
The first species of protohuman
was discovered 1,000 miles
from where I was born.
So I'm one of the ancestors,
Australopithecus africanus--
that's 400 million years ago.
Cities have only been
going for 20,000.
What fraction of 400
million is 20,000?
It's a tiny percentage.
Could somebody calculate it?
20,000 out of 400 million--
what percentage?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
is one in 200.
[INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: It's 5%.
AUDIENCE: 0.5%.
JULIAN BEINART: 0.5%.
Yeah.
I conclude from
that we've not even
started sorting out urbanism.
We've got a long way to go.
That should satisfy all of
you who are young enough
to rejoice in the finding.
Tribalism is difficult--
AUDIENCE: How much do
you think that urbanism
will attain a sort of
maturity or homeostasis
because of the population
rather than time?
JULIAN BEINART: Population
projection is uncertain.
I'm going to read you a number
of quotes from various sources
about this phenomenon.
The one that I find
most dramatic touches
on what you've just asked.
"Urbanization in
developing countries
may be the single greatest
change in this century.
It is projected that developing
countries will triple
their built-up urban area
between 2000 and 2030
from 200,000 square kilometers
to 600,000 square kilometers.
These added 400 square
kilometers constructed
in just 30 years equal the
world's built-up urban area
in 2000.
One could say humans are
building a whole new world
at about 10 times the speed in
countries with severe resource
constraints--
natural, fiscal,
administrative, and technical."
Now, if this is correct,
it's impossible.
Even China cannot
build at this speed,
nor does the developing
world, by its nature,
have all of the
resources to do it.
Slum population in the
world is expected--
is now stated at
about 1 billion people
and is stated to double
within the next 25 years.
Let me just-- perhaps I
should have gone through some
of this material with you.
I always forget.
The world's largest
cities is one
of the indices of not very much
other than population size.
New York was the largest
city in the world in 1950.
It's now sixth.
That's in the year 2000.
Of course, this is assuming
that these measurements
are constant.
What constitutes New
York I don't know.
As far as the standard
metropolitan area,
I don't know how that
compares to Kolkata's area.
But you can see the major
European cities, New York,
London, Rhine-Ruhr,
Paris, Chicago,
have diminished in relative
size as the growth of cities has
taken place in Latin
America and Asia--
not yet significantly
in Africa--
certainly very large cities.
The second two pages are just
cuttings from newspapers.
We saw John Snow's
1854 discovery
that cholera was waterborne
and not miasmic in nature.
Here you see cholera now
being used as an index
to determine 19th
century conditions.
Feeding on 19th century
conditions cholera,
spreads in Latin America.
Another phenomenon from this
world, "A Lovely Madness--
Argentina Builds New
Capital in Patagonia."
They didn't build the
capital, but they proposed
building a new capital.
One of the urbanistic outcomes
of large population growth
and independence
has been the notion
that you need to establish your
status through the building
of a new capital.
These have become famous
icons in the world--
Brasilia, par excellence,
but less significantly,
Chandigarh, in the
Punjab, after the division
between Pakistan and India left
the Punjab without a capital.
AUDIENCE: Islamabad.
JULIAN BEINART: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Islamabad in Pakistan.
JULIAN BEINART: Islamabad
in Pakistan, yes--
but the Indian part of
what remains of the Punjab.
I did some work on Chandigarh
with Charles Correa.
We published a piece in a
book we edited on Chandigarh,
published in India in English.
The story of
Chandigarh is very much
the story of trying to
find an appropriate form
for a post-colonial
post-native city.
Gandhi didn't leave
any instructions
on how to build cities.
Neither did Marx.
The great minds of social
change didn't take cities
into account.
Nor Sydney were they
building belaboring questions
of architectural form--
they were too busy
doing other things.
Chandigarh emerged as a
complex mindset somewhere
between Indian leaders imagining
India to be on a progress
transect towards modernism.
There, after all, were few
Indian architects old enough
to be practicing
significantly at the time.
They chose British
architects, who
in turn said they weren't
capable of doing the work
and recommended a French
architect by the name of Le
Corbusier, who came to
India, traveled around India,
and decided on a
sectoral plan, which
he had played with in Bogota
before coming to India,
without telling
anybody, and evolved
a plan which is based on a
series of five highway systems,
although there were no
cars in India at the time.
I checked on the car
population of India in 1950.
It was close to zero, except
for a few thousand cars.
Chandigarh also didn't
look into the future
as far as how people would
develop from a designed point.
First of all, we have
no way of dealing yet
with immigration as a result
of building an economic growth
point.
There's an informal
sector of Chandigarh--
both in Chandigarh and in
the neighboring towns--
which outnumbers Chandigarh now.
Land control is weak.
Although the national government
superintends over Chandigarh,
it sells land illegally
north of the Capitol Complex
and in parts of the famous
drawings of Corbusier
in the Himalayas
in the distance.
I can go on at length
about Chandigarh.
There is no attempt to look at
the genius of Indian urbanism,
native Indian urbanism.
Nobody looked at Jaipur and
tried to make sense of Jaipur.
Everything was to be, in
the grasp of modernism,
a modern project.
At least Louis Kahn, when
he went to build in Dhaka,
looked at the way bricklayers
laid bricks and built
horizontal stripes in
relation to the terraces that
were finished each day.
Chandigarh is now a center which
is historic in nature, much
like an Italian hill town, and
a periphery, which is a chaotic,
apparently.
It's two cities--
the one envisioned
by a single man and
his cousin, the other
built by the free will allowed.
Some of Corbusier's
regulations still stand today.
They are meaningless in
relation to a bicycle shack
on the periphery.
Anyway, that's so
much for Chandigarh.
Chandigarh will stand as an
emblem of India's attempt
to calibrate itself.
And in that sense, one
should feel proud of it.
It could have been better.
A generation later,
some Indian architects
would have done the same thing.
There are buildings
that are going
to stand for a long time--
the law courts, for instance--
whereas the governor's palace
was never built, leaving the--
oh, I'm getting into
too much detail.
You know Chandigarh, or
you should know it well.
Next page is the page of
optimism from a Toronto
newspaper arguing
that things are
going very well in the world--
sharing graphs of decline in
warfare; falling fertility--
not in the poorest countries,
but in inhabited countries;
change in life expectancy
rising everywhere--
sub-Saharan Africa,
they're still under 50;
the environment shows an
enormous drop in the production
of chlorofluorocarbons.
At best, the Third
World does fairly well--
and so on.
Next page gives a
projected number
of slum dwellers by region.
Next page shows projections
for world population--
population growth losing
25% in Eastern Europe.
As you go from east
to west in Europe,
population growth
loses drastically
to the time we get to England,
where it's relatively stable--
Northern Europe, Western
Europe losing 0.2%.
At the same time, the major
population growth in the United
States, plus 33%, is
due to migration more
than anything else.
The worst conditions are in
Western Africa, plus 127%--
122%; middle Africa, plus 175%;
South Central Asia, plus 55%;
Western Asia, plus
79%; Japan, minus 17%.
People migrate to cities
because there's a better chance
in life than where they are.
They're not dumb.
The notion that people are
animals and behave foolishly
in going to cities is
a foolish proposition.
The life lottery
is large in cities.
It's always been that way.
Your daughter can go to
school and marry a rich man.
It's unlikely to
happen in a village.
There's a sanctity numbers
which you cannot deny.
Number two-- staying in the
rural areas is no blessing.
If only the rural areas is what
our romantic vision of nature
suggests--
beautiful landscape,
low involvement in work,
sitting on the porch,
drinking rum at sundown,
all images from the
colonial tourist world.
I grew up in South Africa
with Afrikaans literature
being filled with
images of this kind--
farmers sitting
benightedly on their porch
whilst their black laborers
slaved away in the distance.
And the young daughter
who'd gone to the city
comes back with an
illegitimate child,
and they all mourn the
fact that the country's
been going to the dogs.
[LAUGHTER]
There's no real-- much
though even the Russians
and many ideologies
sanctified the country as well
as the city.
The Communist
Manifesto says, develop
the country and the city.
The fact is that nobody has
really effectively developed
the country.
The United States is
producing more food
on 7% of the
agricultural population
than it started with.
And that's not the
correct statistic.
I haven't got the
statistic in front of me,
but it's something like that.
In South Africa since
apartheid, there's
been enormous
attempts to increase
the amount of agricultural
land owned by Black people.
I think they still
own less than 20%.
Brutal land reform, such as
by Mr. Mugabe in Rhodesia--
not Rhodesia,
Zimbabwe-- has produced
appalling economic results.
We haven't found a
formula for making
the land productive
outside of heavy technology
or corporate production,
which the United States leads
the world in.
There are signs of
migration from rural to city
in India suggesting
that people do both--
have part of their
families in the country
and work in the city and migrate
selectively between them.
These are an intelligent
form of migration.
But it's not yet
considerably large.
So whereas the British, by the
Enclosure of the Commons Act,
took land away from poor
people, forced them into cities,
today the process is that
nobody is taking the land away
from you, except there's
nothing to do on it.
Migration is not
a new phenomenon.
We started off as migrants.
We settled after
400 million years--
took a long time to settle.
[LAUGHTER]
We've only settled for
20,000 years, at best.
But the rural parts of
the world are becoming
more desolate, less inhabited.
The problem with Central Africa
and the highest migration rates
is a combination
of high fertility
rates and urbanization.
You put the two together, and
you have a lethal combination.
AUDIENCE: Aren't there are also
factors of desertification,
desertification a lot
of agricultural land,
and that's part
of that migration?
JULIAN BEINART: It
depends where you are.
I mean, in Israel, agricultural
land is so valuable.
In Cuba, agricultural
is so valuable
because the territory
is so small.
In this country, one flies over
agricultural land endlessly.
And there's no pressure
of densification.
AUDIENCE: Desertification.
JULIAN BEINART: Sorry?
AUDIENCE: Desert.
JULIAN BEINART: (LAUGHING) Oh,
sorry, I thought densification.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: No, no, no.
JULIAN BEINART: Oh, desert.
Yes, the enormous
ecological problems.
Untended land tends
to get into no good
when it's been tended already.
But ecologists know so
much more about this now.
The knowledge of what to
do about dammed rivers,
and undamming rivers,
letting them travel freely
is a major new
ecological thrust.
Population growth is not held
to be a good religious thing.
For the Catholics,
contraception is
forbidden as it tries to
convince the world that it
has an Argentinian
pope who's a man who
stood up against the military.
I'm not sure about that, either.
[LAUGHTER]
But whether that's true or
not, modern man though he is,
he still believes in
the sanctity of life.
So a new world
must look to being
able to cope with
poverty at a mass scale--
urbanized poverty,
not rural poverty.
Although, rural poverty
will remain a phenomena.
There are people who
will remain on the farm,
remain in small villages.
But they won't be a significant
part of the population.
That's the sad part.
I'm just going to read you a
few figures from these texts.
The two best graphic texts
are the exhibition book
from the Cooper Hewitt
exhibition at the United
Nations last year.
You should have
seen the exhibition.
I had a little bit
to do with it--
not saying so because
I want to be proud.
And the book of the
Rockefeller Foundation,
Century of the City--
I refer to both of
these in your reading.
They're the two best
recent publications.
I'm just going to quote
here and there from them.
Many of them are amped
up about figures.
"In a report on the
future economy of India,
Goldman Sachs projects
that 31 villagers
will continue to arrive in
an Indian city every minute
over the next 43 years--
700 million people in all."
Now, how do you incubate
700 million people,
which is more than twice
the population of the United
States, over 43 years?
We'll see.
I won't be around to watch.
Joel Cohen of
Columbia University--
"The world will have to build
one city of one million people
every five days for
the next 42 years
to accommodate the massive
rural-to-city migration."
One city of one million
every five days--
a lot of work to do.
I'd be very happy
in your profession.
You're going to be deluged by
professional responsibilities.
It goes on to talk
about climate change.
60% of the world's
cities are within walking
distance of the sea.
"The coastal provinces of China
experienced a net in-migration
of 17 million people
in just the five
years between 1995 and 2000.
African-- half of those
cities, including Lagos
and [INAUDIBLE]"--"-- they've
shifted to Africa--
"are in the
low-elevation coastal.
Much of Mumbai, India,
home to the largest slum
settlement in the world, is
built essentially on landfill--
city is a continuing target
for weather disasters."
We'll look, in a minute,
at a few positives.
"Almost half the global
population lives on less than
$2.50 a day.
That is more than 3
billion people, almost all
in developing countries.
Even more shocking, the
proportion of people below
the $2.50 per day poverty
line has remained more or less
constant between 1981 and 2005.
According to the World
Bank, the richest 20%
of the world's
population accounts
for 76% of all consumption.
The bottom 40% account
for only 1.5%."
I want you to look at
some cases of optimism.
These are small
situations which have
improved through the energy
of workers themselves.
Before that, this fits
into the new paradigm,
which has emerged over the last
few years, in which theorists
of developing
countries and activists
have argued that the only
resource that people have
is themselves, that what we
call sweat equity or human labor
or adapted human intelligence
is all that people have.
So international organizations,
like Slum Dwellers
International or the
various regional branches
in India and in
Thailand and so on
have the ambition to
not sit around and wait
for charity or benevolent
dictatorship or any
of the other modalities,
but to harness,
to use their intelligence and
their capacity as human beings
to do something about it.
The problem with all of this--
yep?
AUDIENCE: Can I read a
quote from [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART:
Sorry, I can't hear.
AUDIENCE: Can I read a
quote from one of the papers
that I used for my paper--
JULIAN BEINART: Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: --that is related?
JULIAN BEINART:
Please, somebody talk.
I'm tired of talking.
AUDIENCE: OK, it is in
reference of the case
of the slum [INAUDIBLE]
in the South African Cape
Town, Khayelitsha.
JULIAN BEINART:
Khayelitsha, yeah.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, Khayelitsha.
So this person was the director
of development services.
[INAUDIBLE] Talked
a little [INAUDIBLE]
this paper about the people.
He says, talking in
reference [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah,
just read us the quote.
AUDIENCE: All right.
"If we do not start
immediately with meeting
the local communities'
most urgent needs,
we are going to
lose our legitimacy
as a public administration.
And if we do not do it in
the most participatory way
possible," and this is
the most important part,
"we will waste the most
important capital we have,
the dedication of
the people themselves
and their will for change."
JULIAN BEINART: Good.
I think one of the most
impressive examples so far has
been the 300,000-person
suburb of Sao Paulo,
17 kilometers from the center
of Sao Paulo, called Diadema.
Fortunately, they've
published a book called
Diadema and the Informal City.
I don't know-- I don't
think the library has
a copy of this book.
It's a detailed case study
of how Diadema went about
from being one of the most
violent cities in Latin
America, having one of
the highest crime rates,
have having one of the
lowest educational rates,
being one of the worst slums
in Latin America, to being,
now, a town which
attracts industry,
has its first shopping mall.
And it's a story of workers
galvanizing into groups,
exhibiting their power in the
election of city officials,
forcing assistive procedure,
and to create in poor people
a sense of trust by making
things happen in a very
slow but deliberate way--
paving a street, for instance--
slowly building up in
its dimensions until it
can tackle major issues,
such as national financial
intervention.
They go back and forth with the
military over a period of time.
Then Lula gets
elected president.
He's very sympathetic.
And they have enough
evidence to show that they're
worth investing in.
And slowly, infant mortality
rates decline, all of this
happens.
New housing is built.
Older housing is renewed.
People are part of
a process which--
there's teaching in
schools about crime.
Guns are taken away at school.
I mean, a whole
network of things
happened which probably
characterize a good town.
And they know they're
very proud of the fact
that they've emerged from the
worst conditions of slumness,
slumhood, to being a--
along the way were
a couple of themes.
Trust-- poor people
don't easily have trust.
They've never been brought
up to trust anybody
except some intimate
relationship, if they're lucky.
They don't trust the government.
Our government bypasses
them almost completely.
They have no
prospects that anybody
is going to be able
to change the system.
Slowly, the system does change.
And a generation of people
grow up who start believing.
All of this is true in the
other case in the reading, which
I took because it's a man
who deals with housing
finance in Bangkok, who writes
very explicitly about how he
changed his method of working
by allowing people to take part
and using [INAUDIBLE],,
teaching people
how to deal with their money.
Learning how to deal with money
is something to be learned.
Nobody ever taught me.
I still don't know.
It's extraordinary.
You arrive in a modern world.
You've got to buy a house.
Your parents were too old to--
uneducated to-- in
this kind of game.
Where do you learn?
Where is the social instruction?
This is in a middle
class situation.
When my son bought an
apartment in New York,
he was lucky to have a
wife who is an accountant.
So he could remain
being a theorist
while his wife took care
of all the financial stuff.
It's a wonderful combination.
But not many people are lucky
to be married to accountants.
So that piece deals with
the enormous capacity
for microfinance to generate
both a sense of trust.
It's analogous to the
invention of the mortgage
system in England in 1830.
The mortgage system took the
business of borrowing money
away from a crooked
landowner person, put it
in the hands of a bank.
A bank may crook, but it
has to crook on a very much
larger scale than you.
And the mortgage
system enabled trust
in the purchase of
housing in a way
that had never existed before.
You were always at the
behest of your landlord.
You get these
stories of La Boheme
and La Traviata
in Paris, artists
living in the top floor of
a Haussmann Boulevard house
and the knock on
the door, saying
haven't paid your rent
for the last few months.
What are you going to do?
And you're starving
of tuberculosis.
So that image is no longer
present, or not largely present
in the mortgage system.
A microfinance system is
analogous to the mortgage
system in the building of trust.
98% of the loans engendered
in India in microfinance
have been repaid, which is an
incredible statistic, given
the general condition of
poverty and the lawlessness
that it insinuates.
OK, the trouble with
seeing good things happen
is that sometimes
good things need
to happen at a very large
scale for them really
to make a big impact.
Scaling up Diadema
is difficult. How
do you get the idea to occur
in Tanzania, or in the Congo,
in Darfur?
But at least they
are a small model.
Now, maybe we will not
need massive international
cooperation to
generate new models.
I despair, given
the track record
of League of Nations, United
Nations, atomic energy,
and climate carbon
control agreements.
As long as you
ask the poor world
to subdue their economic
activity, industrial activity,
on the grounds that they are
contributing to climate change,
they rightfully can point
to the United States
having built up its economy
through smoke and railroads
and now, being the largest
client for carbon production
in the world, complaining.
Even the United States wouldn't
sign the Kyoto Agreement,
in Copenhagen got no further.
So I leave you with optimism
and a kind of foreboding.
A combination of climate
change and poverty
is a disastrous combination.
Its effects will be
particularly felt
in water-borne cities like
Dhaka, in the Himalaya region.
The Himalayas control very much
of the flood and drought cycles
in the areas it reaches.
Wealth will be able to withstand
climate change, by and large.
It will modify behavior, but
it will increase migration
pressure on the United
States and on Europe
and on established countries.
I don't think United
States television
could stand having
children floating
in water in Bangladesh
without changing its migration
attitude.
Migration is now under
debate in this country.
As a migrant, I
myself, of course
I'm in favor of migration.
Statistically, we have
built this country.
There are more foreign-born
professors in this school
than there are
Americans, I think.
I don't know.
There'll be one less soon.
[LAUGHTER]
These are all trajectories
for the long future,
but not so long.
It's already 2013.
Some of these
predictions are for 2030.
And there's no respite
except for the people
who believe that science has
no way of forecasting change.
Anyway, these are dull topics.
[LAUGHTER]
There's not much that you can
go out and do about it except
buy yourself a hybrid
car and eat green.
The trouble with climate
change-- it's too invisible.
It's not dramatic enough to
stir the public conscience.
You think of the
German Holocaust.
In 1936, when Berlin
had the Olympic Games,
there were concentration
camps within miles,
on the outskirts of Berlin.
Avery Brundage, the leader
of the American delegation,
castigated New York Jews
in The New York Times
for making a story of it.
The United States
refused to take
in a boat of people fleeing the
Holocaust because they weren't
legal citizens, and
so on and so on.
The demonstration
of the Holocaust
over 10 years of visibility was
neglected by almost everybody.
I don't have much trust in
the universal consciousness.
The world doesn't
have any conscience.
It only has selective
consciousness,
often in service of private
good and national good.
The more Boston goes
on about being strong,
the more I read a kind of
perverse nationalism creeping
in--
again, identifying yourself
as able to be a Goliath
withstanding the treachery
of two young men.
Anyway, these are my
personal positions.
I don't know what you
think about your future.
[LAUGHS] I grew up with the
advantage of being a modernist.
And the world was
very attractive--
if only we could slay all
those 19th century devils.
It's amazing to
me to know that--
to think that I studied
modern architectural history
with Sigfried
Giedion at Harvard.
In Giedion, in all of
his teaching to us--
after all, he wrote Space,
Time and Architecture, which
was a big book at my day--
Giedion only referred to
the terrible ruling tastes
of the 19th century,
that it wasn't producing
architects of any consequence.
He never mentioned
anything to do with a city,
not in all of his evocation,
class after class of modernism.
He'd said, oh, it's attractive
that we've grown up.
At least I think we've grown up.
We're beginning to grow up.
We talk about architecture being
inseparable from urbanism now.
And yet we don't teach
urban history at all.
This is the closest
class you're going to get
to dealing with urban history.
And I know a historian,
and he uses a sneaky method
to introduce history.
[LAUGHTER]
Not being sure of the
detailed facts myself,
I have to conjure up clever,
tricky ways of convincing you.
There's no
architecture curriculum
in the world that doesn't
require architectural history
as a major element
of its discourse.
There's no field in the arts--
literature, painting,
music-- that
doesn't require an understanding
of its predecessors.
You can play the horn
as much as you want to,
but you better know Mozart,
or at least one symphony
of Mozart, in your exams.
You can be an
architectural graduate
with not knowing one
city plan in history.
City plans are
difficult to remember,
and I wouldn't want to
be given an exam asking
me to draw 10 city plans.
Chandigarh is easy.
Manhattan is easy.
Once you depart-- anyway,
so go and finish your work.
Have a great summer.
And I'll see you on Thursday
if you have the time.
So much for the world of--
the developing-- Ricardo,
what do you think
is going to happen in Mexico?
AUDIENCE: Ooh.
[LAUGHTER]
JULIAN BEINART: No, in relation
to our general discussion
this morning?
AUDIENCE: I think there
was a lot of discussion
around Mexico City.
But I think that most
people tend to neglect
what's happening in
mid-sized cities in Mexico--
so not necessarily places
like Monterrey or Guadalajara,
but actually places like
Puebla, [INAUDIBLE],,
which are a big part of the
backbone of where Mexico lives,
places like [INAUDIBLE].
And they fear that they're
often thought of as basically
an afterthought.
But you see cities there, like
Tijuana, like [INAUDIBLE],, who
are really experimenting
and pushing things forward,
for that population,
is very interesting--
not necessarily the following
the model of [INAUDIBLE]..
So it's interesting
that they are--
JULIAN BEINART: Is
there any movement
that combines these efforts?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Yeah, there are some programs.
There are some programs by the
federal government [INAUDIBLE]
urban sustainable development.
And within each
city, there tends
to be a local grassroots
movements that
are sort of pushing
the urban development.
AUDIENCE: What is it mean?
AUDIENCE: DUIS.
It's easier if you
just look at DUIS.
AUDIENCE: But what
does it stand for?
AUDIENCE: It's Wholly
Sustainable Urban Developments.
AUDIENCE: Wholly Sustainable
Urban Development.
AUDIENCE: Wholly?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
It's a program from the
federal government that
finances housing [INAUDIBLE]
Mexico is building
about 950,000 houses a year.
So there is a lot
going on there.
It's interesting
times down there,
as in many places in
Latin America, actually.
JULIAN BEINART: Yeah.
Well, let's hope.
This class was not
to depress you.
AUDIENCE: Sorry?
JULIAN BEINART: I said,
this class was not
designed to depress you.
[LAUGHTER]
On the contrary, you could
simply say, over 10,000 years,
we achieved achieve more
than 400 million before us.
And there's many
benefits that have come
from urbanization in our time.
Maybe it will continue--
but hopefully, less selectively
than it's been up to now.
There's no law that asks
you to be a social animal.
You can't drive into
somebody else's garden
and get away with it.
But there's nothing
that requires
you to see your own condition in
the light of other people less
fortunate.
Charity was invented
by the British.
Well, charity has
been with us forever.
But at the end of
the 19th century,
charity was seen as the
major involvement of wealth.
It still is in this country.
I get upset every time
I get a phone call
asking me to donate something
and trying to reconstruct
my own ideology, which is not
in favor of charity at all,
but charity being only a method
of conceding the government's
inaction.
There's no-- I don't know.
It's very complicated.
It's very fundamentally
complicated as to who was--
why was I statistically
born to have enough money
to come and study here and then
have enough energy to stay?
I'll never be able to answer--
as opposed to a child growing
up in the Congo today.
What statistical right do
I have over that child?
These are questions
philosophers have argued with.
They may be tedious.
But Marxism didn't
solve the problem.
Marxism only introduced
a new form of power,
despite all of the
grassroots sentiments,
it didn't result in anything.
OK, see you next week--
I'll see you later this week.